[Musique]
ap
à
j'ai des amis qui souhaiterait bien
avoir des prévisions
même s'ils n'ont pas eu le temps
nécessaire de rencontrer un médecin mais
ils veulent quand même avoir à la
chloroquine à la maison voilà si j'eusse
en guise de prévention
pour lui la majorité de nos patients
viennent vers nous pour nous demander de
la chloroquine pourront mettre un stop
au pas ou quelqu'un de leur famille le
corona ils ont déjà anticipé mais il
faut aussi bien que les explique que
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
comment l'aristo c'est ça
avec tout ce qui se passe il ya beaucoup
de clients qui viennent demander la
clause malheureusement
cette spécialité ce soit sous forme de
nivaquine ou autre n'est pas disponible
actuellement dans les officines de faras
[Applaudissements]
16 87
ça prenait
[Musique]
il